[Music]
since world war one number stations have
been transmitting coded messages to
spies
around the world using shortwave radio
and they're still transmitting
right now at the height of the cold war
radio listeners around the world started
to notice
strange broadcasts starting with a weird
melody or tone
these transmissions were followed by the
unnerving sound of a woman's robotic
voice
counting in german
where the creepy voice of a child
reciting letters in english
now these transmissions sound strange to
casual listeners but to the right set of
ears
they contain information that could
change the course of history
in fact number stations have changed the
course of history
let's find out why
[Music]
welcome to the y files where cool nerds
laugh and learn hey
we gonna talk about this what hello who
who's the new guy what's he talking
about him am i new
no space panda you're fine anyway
even though we're in the age of
satellites and broadband wi-fi and cyber
warfare
it could be that the old-fashioned radio
is the real tool
of the new world order if you want to
conspire with spies
governments and illuminati right so if
your plan is to oppress the masses
you don't want to leave a digital trail
so instead you broadcast encrypted
details of your evil plot
over shortwave radio also known as
number stations
you may have heard that number stations
are a relic of the past but number
stations are active
and being used right now we're going to
listen to a few in this episode
one of the best known number stations
was the lincolnshire poacher
named after the folk song played as an
identifying signal
three nine seven well that's pretty
creepy
it is a couple of radio nerds slash
heroes
use direction finding equipment to
triangulate this station's location
the transmission was coming from a royal
air force base in cyprus
this station is believed to have been
operated by mi6
from the mid-1970s all the way to 2008
one of the creepiest stations ever
was called swedish rhapsody it used a
child's music box and a child's voice
to read numbers in german
[Music]
this number station was operated for
almost 50 years
by the polish secret police no that
gives me chills
you can get chills underwater hey do me
a favor will you
what don't hush my fuzz
and my favorite number station of all
time is yosemite sam whose voice is
played as part of the transmission the
broadcast
begins on one of several frequencies
then 10 seconds later it's repeated on
the next higher frequency
and so on and so on for a total of two
minutes the entire pattern takes exactly
two minutes and always begins seven
seconds after the top of the hour
spies need to be punctual each broadcast
starts with a data burst
lasting 0.8 seconds followed by the
voice of
yosemite sam saying
you're kidding me nope that's a number
station broadcasting from a government
contractor in new mexico
don't tell me they're connected to
lockheed martin well
great the two amateur radio operators
slash heroes
tracked down the source of the yosemite
sam broadcasts in february 2005.
the tower was located at the mobility
assessment test and integration center
also known as matic this is part of a
factory owned by laguna industries
located near laguna new mexico
the guys went down there and took
photographs of a compound containing
buildings
towers and antennas but quickly fled
when they were approached by a security
guard yelling at them to not take any
pictures
just three hours later the broadcast
stopped and have not been heard since
what did laguna industries have to say
about it oh laguna industries removed
all references to matic from their
website
and now that website is gone not
suspicious at all
okay so what are number stations well
number stations are simply shortwave
radio transmitters
generally operating between three
thousand and thirty thousand kilohertz
they're located in many countries all
over the world but no one really knows
how many there are
the stations sometimes transmit numbers
spoken by a computer-generated voice
which is how number stations got their
name
but other broadcast morse code
compressed data bursts
or beloved cartoon characters now some
stations have been broadcasting for
decades
many have gone quiet since the end of
the cold war
what now the cold war is alive and well
my friend
well it's not a very enlightened point
of view uh wake up furface
i beg your pardon if you're a dumb
enough to think you're right
i don't know what to tell you because
one more or another for them
forgive me uh do continue oh yeah do
continue
anyway countless number stations are on
the air right now for what purpose
do you really know and the people that
do know they aren't talking
one anonymous intelligence agent from
the uk said
number stations are exactly what you
think they are and that's all i'll say
about it so in almost every country
a license is required to broadcast but
number stations aren't licensed
they're essentially pirate stations
operating illegally
but nobody shuts them down and no
government acknowledges they even exist
that's because number stations are the
government
okay normally i'd call hecklefish a kook
for saying that yay
but this time he's right i'm always
right about this stuff
amateur detectives radio buffs and
investigative journalists
have been studying number stations for
years there's enough information out
there that we can assume that these
transmissions have a single purpose
espionage all the messages were
encrypted that they became digits
and the digits would be sent over as in
groups of five
shortwave radio is old technology in the
late 1920s it was a popular way to
communicate over long distances because
of the way the waves travel which is
called
propagation space panda the earth's
ionosphere is a region of space between
80 and 600 kilometers
above the surface shortwave radio energy
can bounce high off the earth's
ionosphere
and come back down to the earth
sometimes over and over again
this allows the signal to travel great
distances
oh don't you two make quite the team
this is called sky wave or skip
propagation with a decent radio you can
tune into a strong shortwave signal from
the other side of the planet now that's
pretty useful if you're an intelligence
agency and you need to send secret
messages to agents and assets in the
field
also computerized messages can be hacked
tracked and traced
but no one can trace who's receiving a
shortwave radio signal and it's hard to
find the source of a transmission and if
you know the right frequency
anyone can eavesdrop on an international
spy network
including you you can find tons of
frequencies online
and i'll link to some websites in the
description now what you'll hear depends
on the station
some stations broadcast constantly
others power up schedule time so agents
in the field know when to tune in
you're going to hear a lot of spanish
czech chinese
hebrew but you know where most of the
spy stations are
i know you're not going to say russia
yeah yep
now the broadcast you'll hear on number
stations vary but they generally begin
with an alert signal and this alert may
be a simple tone
or it could be fragments of a song such
as the lincolnshire poacher
the swedish rhapsody all kinds of other
ones and this alert
indicates to listeners that a message is
about to begin and also gives a few
seconds to tune in the radio for the
best reception
after the tone is usually a set of
spoken numbers or letters
often four or five at a time which are
repeated again and again before moving
on to a new set
there are a lot of variations on the
same structure many stations have
received nicknames that reflect the
station depending on what's being
broadcast
names like the buzzer cherry ripe the
spanish lady
uh the russian woodpecker was a great
one atencion
yosemite sam and swedish rhapsody i'll
have
a whole bunch more in the description
now sometimes broadcasts are really
clear
but other times atmospheric conditions
can degrade the signals
and sometimes intentional jamming from
other countries creates enough
interference on the frequency
that makes transmission difficult to
understand so
to compensate many stations like
yosemite sam will hop around to
different frequencies
tradecraft the coded structure of the
messages
indicates that these messages are indeed
secret and intended to avoid detection
the question then is how do spies
understand these messages when no one
else can
that was a static filled triple
scrambled microwave transmission between
two soldiers talking in mandarin chinese
well the chinese were only using a
simple polyphonically grouped 20 square
digit key transposed in booster vidonic
form with multiple nulls
so even though they're very low tech
number stations are still in use because
unlike computer code these transmissions
are unbreakable
nothing is unbreakable these messages
might be
so what's so hard about deciphering a
few numbers
actually it's nearly impossible here's
how spies in the field encode and decode
their messages
first you start with a block of
randomized text that's your one-time pad
key
then take your message here we're using
the name jimmy smith
two five-letter words then you have a
cipher chart
this is a grid of a to z and zero to 9
on the x
and y axis now set up your message
matching the first five letters or jimmy
with the first five letters from the pad
then match up the word smith
with the second set of letters okay now
find the first letter of your message on
the x-axis
then find the letter underneath on the
y-axis
where the axes intersect that's your
coded character
repeat this for all your letters and
your message is ready to transmit
to decrypt the message set up the coded
characters in groups of five
match those up at the pad then find the
first letter of the key on the y-axis
then move across until you hit the coded
letter the character at the top of the
grid is your decoded character
and thanks to vhs blog for setting this
up awesome so both the sender and
receiver
immediately destroy the key at the end
of the transmission so even if someone
else intercepts the numbers
which i have without the key they have
no way to decode the hidden message
this also means there's no relationship
between past or future messages so
there's no pattern to use
in breaking the code to fool
cryptographers the numbers must be
really really random and creating truly
random numbers is actually
really difficult even for computers but
once in a while the broadcasts are
less than professional the person
reading the code may make mistakes
or there could be laughing in the
background cuban number stations in
particular are known for their
hilarious missteps sometimes they've had
such poor transmissions
that they're impossible to hear or they
accidentally pipe music from radio
havana onto the airwaves
i would hazard to guess they are more
foreign intelligence officers inside the
u.s
working against u.s interests now than
even at the height of the cold war
some number stations have illicit uses
drug lords and other criminals use
shortwave to avoid international
authorities
this is especially true in the us where
many intercepted signals are broadcast
in spanish
since they don't have government
oversight the execution is pretty sloppy
right because the government is never
sloppy in its execution well the fish
does make a good point
but those number stations are pretty
rare espionage is the most common use
there are even some very public and
recent examples of this
in 1983 the kgb uncovered a cia agent
posing as a soviet diplomat who is
receiving orders from american numbers
broadcasts
another well-known case is the 2001
cuban 5 case
where cuban spies were caught and
shortwave broadcasts were used in the
case against them as evidence
also in 2001 anna montez who worked for
the u.s defense intelligence agency
was arrested and convicted of spying for
cuba investigators searched her home and
found a shortwave radio
along with a code sheet that was used to
encrypt radio transmissions
now she exposed the identities of covert
operators in cuba
and her information was directly
responsible for the death of at least
one american soldier
maybe more in 2016 cnn called montes
the most dangerous spy you've never
heard of although
now you've heard of her and to this day
and despite this mountain of evidence
no government or intelligence agency has
ever officially admitted to using number
stations
today we're going to be discussing a
radio set not just any radio set
but a russian radio set so you don't
need a radio to listen to spy
communications
you can listen to the entire shortwave
band online and i'll link below
because these receivers are operated by
software they can be used remotely by
everyone in the world and here's what
one of those tuners looks like
[Music]
now if you're not a radio nerd that
might look a little weird but if you
want to dig in further
i'll link to a tutorial up there and
down in the description
i'll also link to priam.org station
schedule which is super cool it lets you
tell
exactly when number stations are coming
on the air and what frequency you need
to listen
now i'm thinking about doing a live
stream of this so if you want to see
that
let me know in the comments if you just
want to binge station broadcasts you can
go down a whole rabbit hole with the
conette project the connect project was
an independent initiative to record
catalog and inform the public about the
secret transmissions that are around us
in the air every day you can even
download the files as mp3s for
later analysis oh i'm gonna need a
pencil
my tinfoil hat and a tall glassy whiskey
i'm sorry but
do you have any sherry no eva give me a
break
the quantity of number stations has
dropped dramatically over the past few
years
still the broadcasts continue are they
feeding invaluable information to
operatives on crucial missions
or are they just holdovers from
government agencies protecting their
budgets
both probably it could also be that
governments maintain the stations for
readiness purposes
if the power grid or internet goes down
a shortwave transmitter just needs an
antenna and a diesel generator and they
could be on the air
broadcasting around the world but as
communication technology continues to
evolve
and digital encryption gets harder to
crack we might finally see the end of
number stations
or maybe the opposite will occur maybe
some catastrophic digital apocalypse
will create a number station renaissance
pushing broadcasters back onto the front
lines of international intelligence
where random numbers raining down from
the ionosphere
can once again change the course of
human history
thanks for hanging out with us today my
name is aj that's heckle fish space
panda
this has been the y files if you had fun
or learned anything today help us out by
liking
commenting or sharing this video the
algorithm is a fearsome enemy
but with your help we can defeat it we
have done the impossible
and that makes us mighty okay i gotta
admit that was pretty good
until next time be safe be kind and know
that you
are appreciated
[Music]
you